[Music]
so you're a part of the one percent but
ironically
even though you've already given back
more to the world than 99 of the
population ever will
not including bankers or else you
wouldn't be a millionaire or billionaire
the world you enrich thinks that you
should be punished the most that you
need to pay your fair share with their
greedy progressive tax system
where the more value you create the more
taxes you have to pay to uncle sam
now obviously we don't want to pay all
those hefty taxes after all why would we
sure there are legitimate things
governments need money for but for the
most part they're just going to waste
the majority of your hard-earned money
anyways like how the government funded a
near 600 000
study in 2011 in part to find out why
chimps throw poop at each other
yes this really happened your money is
always better off in your more nobler
hands
and hey if you're feeling charitable you
can always donate some of your wealth
like many do
directly to causes you believe in when
you know exactly what your money is
going towards
there comes a time in every successful
businessman's life where you're making
so much money that you're better off
learning how to rip off uncle sam in
legitimate and not legitimate ways
theoretically of course
than actually growing your business more
and let's face it the legitimate ways of
avoiding taxes are pretty boring
so this is how the wealthy elite
illegally not pay their fair share
[Music]
this video was sponsored by trends which
is probably the internet's most
undiscovered knowledge has for
entrepreneurs to find the next big
business idea before it explodes
trends is a part of the hustle the daily
business and technology email newsletter
read by over a million readers every
morning
you get a first look at emerging markets
you can network with over 5 000
investors startup ceos and aspiring
entrepreneurs just like you
and you get private exclusive access to
their invaluable content library which i
know you guys are going to love reading
so stop what you're doing pause the
video and get your first two weeks of
trends for just one dollar by going to
trends.co
jake right now the link is on the screen
and in the video description below
not paying taxes is a puzzle a game of
cat and mouse between you the would-be
taxpayer and the greedy tax collectors
the government
what you have to understand is that the
entire lifeblood of the government
depends on tax dollars to survive and
thrive
governments are made up of very
power-hungry people that would prefer to
stay in power
so if you threaten their rule by
withholding their lifeblood especially
if you're a big fish
they will pull out all the guns to track
you down and make sure you suffer
with prison time about the 5 years for
each count of tax evasion and finds out
the 250 thousand dollars for individuals
and 500 000
for corporations the problem is that
when you operate a business that is
registered in the majority of modern
countries like the us
you're legally required to have your
name on the business in one way or
another
sure a business can own another business
there are some states like delaware that
allow for anonymous companies
but if everything is under u.s
jurisdiction the irs will eventually be
able to trace it back to you
if they really wanted to the key is
getting your name off the business off
of any paperwork and to make sure that
even if the us
really wanted to with a warrant let's
say they can never find out who actually
owns the business
because if they don't know who owns the
business well they won't know who to
charge for tax evasion
the problem is that like we mentioned if
everything is under u.s jurisdiction
your name has to be on your business in
one way or another
this is where shell companies come in
show companies are official companies
that you can open and control but can't
be traced back to you
this way you can open up a shell company
move your money through it and since
your name isn't attached to the shell
company
tax collectors won't be able to charge
you shell companies can do
anything open up a bank account enter
into complex business transactions
buy stuff sell stuff etc the problem is
that there is no way in hell countries
like the us would allow for full-blown
shell companies to be created
because why would they give you a
bulletproof way to avoid paying up
again there are states like delaware
that allow for some anonymity
but it's not nearly as morally lenient
as other places
enter tax havens
tax havens are usually small countries
that don't really have much going for
them so they offer an extremely enticing
business environment to attract foreign
businesses to work with them and collect
fees
there are exceptions but when you look
at the majority of tax havens around the
world this is usually the case
take nauru for example nauru is the
third smallest country in the world at
only eight square miles northeast of
australia
not really much going for it
economically but in 2001 nauru was
internationally blacklisted because
nations were worried it had become a
center for money laundering
there are four main qualifiers that make
a country a tax haven number one the
country has little or no taxes
number two they have very convenient
financial products and incentives like
shell companies for foreigners
but don't allow those very same
financial products to be used within the
country domestically
take malta for example a tiny island off
the coast of sicily
local multi businesses have to pay a
whopping 35 tax on all profits
yet foreign corporations only have to
pay as little as five percent
the number three thing that makes a
country a tax haven is that the
financial activities of the country lack
transparency
and lastly and most importantly the
country doesn't cooperate with other
countries to give away their clients
identities
preferably not revealing client
information to authorities is required
by law
along with these four main points little
or no taxes great financial products for
foreigners little or no transparency and
no cooperation with authorities
you also want to be absolutely sure your
tax haven also has these things
the country needs to have a stable
economy and political climate
shifting power can lead to someone
taking over that isn't so lenient with
foreign businesses and might even seize
your assets
like how this happened in cuba with the
mafia and the economy has to be
entrenched and dependent on their
financial industry
the more a tax haven depends on this
financial sector the more the economy
depends
on dirty money the less likely they'll
ever be to change their tax haven
reputation and will even actively
encourage it
although this isn't a hundred percent
guarantee that the country will never
get stricter as we'll cover
later it does help mitigate your risk
the best tax havens have locals that
accept some level of corruption in order
to keep the money flowing
or in other words tax havens need to
have a symbiotic relationship with
reluctant foreign taxpayers
the country gets to collect fees employ
their people and in return
the foreign companies get a haven and
protection from the state itself
there needs to be a strong incentive for
them not to screw you over
some of the biggest tax havens right now
include the island of jersey between
france and the uk
the island of bermuda in the atlantic
the cayman islands with the biggest one
being the british virgin
islands where their economy holds more
than 5 000 times the value of what an
economy its size should hold
once you have a tax haven in mind it's
time to start your show company
here's how opening up a shell company
usually works first you're going to
choose a company in that tax haven that
offers these financial services for sale
although you can buy shell companies
online if you're a very well-off
individual
you're probably going to want to have
your lawyer accountant or banker be the
intermediary that deals with these
companies to make sure everything is on
the up and up
you can either buy a brand new shell
company or they'll have existing ones
that have a history of transactions
already to make it look more legitimate
which costs
extra once you purchase a shell company
now you have some decisions to make
who is going to be the shareholder of
the company even though your name can't
be legally released in many tax havens
if you choose yourself as a shareholder
would you want to risk having your name
on company papers
for the extra paranoid some havens like
the british virgin islands and panama
let companies offer bearer shares
these are nameless stock certificates
where whoever physically possesses the
pieces of paper
owns the company this means the firm
issuing the stocks can't track the owner
and transferring ownership for a company
is as simple as handing the pieces of
paper to someone else
no paper trail once you determine the
shareholder of the company
now it's time to choose the directors
although tax havens don't require the
owners of a company to be publicly
listed they do require directors of a
company too
not to worry though because these
financial firms offer what's known as
nominee directors
cheap employees of the financial firm
that only control your company on paper
while you retain all your power via a
secret power of attorney agreement
these pencil pushers signed documents
for you will hold meetings on paper
open up bank accounts for you etc and
these financial firms will even have
these directors pre-signed legal
templates that can be used for future
clients that come in
some of these employees are directors on
100 plus shell companies
once you have directors now it's time to
open up a bank account under your new
anonymous shell company
offshore companies are worthless without
a bank account because bank accounts are
required to do any significant
transaction
so this is a pretty important step i'd
like to open a bank account
oh bless you i'll be right back
and now your new shell company is pretty
much good to go what's great is that
since these financial firms are really
just registering paperwork with a local
government they're in a very competitive
low margin business
which means all your needs are pretty
affordable with some estimates pointing
around fifteen hundred to four thousand
dollars to open up a shell company in
the british virgin islands
depending on how special your needs are
expect to pay a little more
now it's time to put your tax haven to
work
remember our goal is to not pay taxes so
the first step is to move our money
offshore into our show so it can't be
taxed
there are an endless amount of options
here to get an idea common methods
include routing transactions to tax
havens and skimming money off the top
into your offshore accounts
creating fake invoices to pay your shell
company for services that never happened
selling assets to your shell company at
a big loss and the list goes on
and as with any less than legal activity
the more creative you are with it the
more unexpected your strategy the
less likely you are to get caught if you
do what everyone else does you're going
to get caught with everyone else
more on this later then you have to
eventually get that money back home
because after all cash is useless
offshore one clever way to go about this
is the fact that you don't have to own
something to
enjoy it maybe you bought a giant yacht
with your shell company
you could lease it back to yourself at a
very fair price
another way tax bypassers got around
this back in the day is via credit cards
that these offshore banks offered
where you could anonymously use that
credit card back home to draw down your
offshore account balance
until they started cracking down on this
since all the transactions are rather
through us servers
and you have to do all of this while
making sure that it doesn't look like
you're secretly controlling your
offshore company
and that your intent looks legitimate
absolutely
[Music]
not that you really were paying for a
service that this far away company
offered
and that yeah this company also offered
to lease me a yacht at a very reasonable
price
if metaling authorities sniff any
potential wrongdoing these are the
things they're going to look at how you
entered the offshore world how you got
your money offshore and how you got it
back to shore
and boom once you pick a tax haven open
up a shell company with a local
financial firm and get your operation
going you are now paying a glorious zero
percent tax on all the money you manage
to get through your offshore shell
companies
the bigger you scale up the bigger
portion of your profits can avoid going
into elko sam's coffers
but just because they might not be able
to legally release your name and just
because tax evasion will never go away
doesn't mean tax havens are foolproof
remember we're messing with the
lifeblood of world governments
and when you push someone into a corner
they're gonna play every trick in the
book to defeat you
in 2015 the eu released a list of
blacklisted tax havens
blacklisted countries face sanctions and
they also had a great list of countries
that will go on the blacklist if they
don't make tax reforms
in 2019 the cayman islands promised it
will release the names of
everyone who owns accompanied lara by
2023. this was due to pressure from the
uk and the eu
and it doesn't have to be governments
that ruin the party either in 2016 a
whistleblower leaked documents that
exposed more than 200 000
offshore companies and their owners
names to journalists from one firm
called mozak fonseca in panama the names
include the king of saudi arabia former
presidents of argentina
ukraine ecuador former prime ministers
of iceland
italy georgia iraq pakistan australia
and countless of other smaller
government officials from practically
every major country
and tons and tons of prominent
celebrities and business people
so what i'm trying to say is you
shouldn't evade taxes because it's bad
i mean just stay safe stay creative
don't penny pinch in this arena and for
the love of god
make sure you cover up your tracks
theoretically of course
so in summary this is all pretty simple
step number one
make money step number two use shell
companies in tax havens to rip off uncle
sam
do i even have to say theoretically but
none of this convoluted stuff even
matters if you don't get past step
number one
how to start making money in business
one of the most common questions we get
on this channel
if you look at any industry whether it
be youtubers or big tech companies
usually the most successful ones in that
space that make the majority of the
money
are the ones that jumped on new trends
early on you don't have to be exactly
first in an industry but being the best
early on when things aren't saturated
makes life a whole lot easier
so if you want to get to the point where
you're making an astronomical amount of
money that's worth evading taxes for
what you need is the next big trend the
next big thing
this is where trends come in one of the
best little known knowledge hubs for
entrepreneurs like you to find your next
business idea network
learn and maybe even discover the next
big thing my favorite feature of trends
are the signals
detailed yet easy to digest articles
that analyzes what do you know
the next big trends like this signal on
how to capitalize on the new billion
dollar open banking industry
or this signal on exactly what startups
got funded in july
or this really cool signal on the
growing trends of peer-to-peer learning
drop servicing
and bamboo plants or ways to capitalize
off of this pandemic
you're also able to easily network with
over 5 000 entrepreneurs investors
startup ceos and hustlers just like you
and they also have some really
impressive articles on q and a's with
big entrepreneurs practical how-to
guides analyzing different industries
like this one called the rent everything
industry
as americans ditch ownership just around
300 startups exist in the rental goods
space
and i've been genuinely impressed with
how unique the business insights you get
with trends
is so stop what you're doing right now
and get your first two weeks of trends
for just one dollar by going to
trends.co
jake right now the link is on the screen
and in the video description below and
start working towards making that tax
invasion worldly money while also
supporting the brands that help make
this channel possible
welcome to the watchland club as you can
see we're still not at the studio yet
because i still haven't gotten around to
it
so we are here if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you
click the subscribe button and the like
button and all that other stuff down
below for more video essays just like
this one
every single week you can follow me on
instagram for like memes and behind the
scenes kind of stuff kind of like this
stuff
so if you want to join us over there
it's at jaketrend.io this video was
based on the book secrecy world which
was turned into the movie on netflix
called the laundromat
extremely funny movie if you haven't
seen it already highly recommend it and
the book if you want to learn more so
that's gonna wrap it up for this video
thank you so much for watching you've
been awesome
i've been jake stay dangerous and i'll
see you guys in the next one
[Music]